I love Kareem he's one of my favorite
people I have a great photo signed by
Kareem me and him it's SiriusXM where
he's just standing up towering oh it's
such a good moment in life he's on the
show yeah but this was before I he was
going to be interviewed by somebody else
so I went with a basketball I mean I
really am the [__] worst white piece
of [__] he must have hated me
um I was in a baggie and he says to me
of course
and he goes uh the only thing worse
I I literally should have been wearing
my [__] my purple and yellow outfit
and he goes I know you and he knew me
because I was on an episode of bored to
death with Jason Schwartzman and he goes
oh yeah I know you from that show so I
was like we take a picture together he
said yeah sure we took a picture that's
the best and uh he didn't want to sign
the ball so then he was kind of like he
didn't want to be rude so he but I got
it to me you know it just says to Jim
Abdul-Jabbar and uh that's crazy I'll
never sell it you know I mean